[Aplausos]
[Música]
este es un gran lugar para trabajar esto
es lo que hijo donald trump refiriéndose
a la casa blanca a principios de marzo
de 2018 horas antes de hacerse pública
la dimisión de su principal asesor
económico y con sus guerras
[Música]
en cualquier otro momento esta frase no
hubiese tenido nada de particular no
hubiese llamado la atención
absolutamente de nadie al fin y al cabo
la casablanca y no creo que sea algo que
sorprenda a nadie es uno de los lugares
más cotizados del mundo para trabajar
tener un empleo en el equipo del
presidente supone poder influencia y
reconocimiento sin embargo amigos
esperado un momento porque nos estamos
olvidando de algo de un detalle muy
importante de quién es el presidente de
eeuu y de cómo es su particular carácter
lo sabéis bien en el diccionario trump
el término habitual no tiene cabida no
existe no me creéis pues atentos
[Música]
turbulencias en el ala oeste
en enero de 2017 juraron su cargo las 23
personas más importantes del ala oeste
de la casa blanca' es decir las personas
que compondrían el equipo más cercano al
presidente el jefe de gabinete el
secretario de prensa el consejero de
seguridad nacional el director de
comunicaciones etcétera etcétera es
decir todas esas personas que solemos
ver en las series y en las películas al
lado del presidente claro que amigos
donald no es yo sea barlett y sobrevivir
en su administración empieza a ser más
difícil que montar un negocio en la
venezuela de nicolás maduró un momento
no sabéis quién es yo sea barlett no
habéis visto the west wing el ala oeste
de la casa blanca' pues si es así no
perdáis ni un minuto es una serie muy
pero que muy recomendable si te gusta la
política pero no nos desviemos
regresemos a la casa blanca de donald
trump
sabéis cuántas de estas 23 personas que
formaban la guardia pretoriana del
presidente cuando comenzó este su
mandato continúan hoy en el cargo pues
de 23 apenas continúan 9 y algunos de
estos 9 están en la cuerda floja pero
puede que estés pensando bueno parece
que se equivocó al elegir oye un error
lo tiene cualquiera pues el problema es
que ahí no termina todo
keith flint anthem pas una investigadora
del brookings institute uno de los más
importantes think tanks de washington
está siguiendo minuciosamente los
cambios que se están produciendo
prácticamente todas las semanas en la
oficina ejecutiva del presidente en el
ala oeste de la casa blanca' pues bien
si tenemos en cuenta a los 23 fichajes
que jugaron su cargo en enero de 2017 a
los cargos que fueron nombrados después
a los que han sido sustituidos cesados o
han dimitido y a las personas que
trabajan para ellos en total han formado
parte de la oficina del presidente hasta
el momento claro 65 personas
pues bien la tasa de rotación es ya del
48 por ciento es decir para que nos
entendamos en poco más de un año la
mitad la mitad de quienes han formado el
equipo ya no están en su puesto
pues bien la tasa de rotación es ya del
48 por ciento una tasa de rotación tan
elevada que no tiene precedentes los
escándalos los desencuentros con el
presidente o simplemente los cambios de
humor del inquilino del despacho oval
han hecho amigos que trabajan hoy en el
ala oeste sea una profesión de alto
riesgo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea los despidos
las divisiones y los cambios se están
sucediendo a una velocidad tres veces
mayor que la de la administración obama
y dos veces la de reagan que hasta ahora
tenía el récord de verdad no estoy
exagerando está siendo una locura en
poco más de un año y atentos porque no
estamos hablando precisamente de puestos
menores trump ha tenido dos secretarios
de prensa dos jefes de gabinete dos
asesores de seguridad nacional y cinco
personas diferentes han sido nombradas
como directores de comunicaciones en
este tiempo donald trump ha despedido
incluso a sus abogados y lo que es peor
según las informaciones disponibles todo
apunta a que las cosas van a ir aún a
peor por ejemplo se da por hecho el
próximo despido del actual asesor de
seguridad nacional el general mcmaster e
incluso también el cese del general john
kelly su actual jefe de gabinete
trump decide despedir a su asesor de
seguridad nacional si donald trump les
escogió pero parece que luego no le han
caído del todo bien así que amigos con
este panorama ya podemos entender por
qué muchos miembros de su equipo según
han confesado se pasan gran parte del
tiempo tratando de no provocar a un
presidente que se enfada muy pero que
muy fácilmente
os imaginais a trump recorriendo los
pasillos de la casa blanca diciendo
despedido despedido despedido pues
parece que la realidad no es muy
distinta sí parece que trump se tomó muy
en serio su puesto en el aprendiz el
popular reality de televisión donde
básicamente despedía a la gente
efe
e iberia
[Música]
el desvastador ningún negocio podría
manejar algo así mucho menos el gobierno
se supone que se necesita continuidad y
estabilidad pero eso no está en su
léxico william daily jefe de gabinete
con barack obama pero vale puede que os
estéis preguntando pero que está pasando
cuáles pueden ser los motivos para
tantos cambios pues la verdad los hay de
todos los tipos y colores
[Música]
algunos se han tenido que marchar
forzados por los escándalos como el
consejero de seguridad nacional michael
flynn o el secretario de personal rock
porter acusado de malos tratos
i
av
este fue también el caso de banon hasta
el mes de agosto de 2017 fue la mano
derecha de donald trump en su carrera
política pero ni siquiera eso le salvó
conocido por sus posiciones muy
nacionalistas estigma no no había sido
nombrado consejero del presidente y jefe
de estrategia de la casa blanca
pues bien pasados poco más de seis meses
atrás decidió echarle al final vano se
adelantó y presentó una dimisión forzada
otros como el asesor económico y el
directivo de goldman sachs erik con el
secretario de prensa son spicer se han
marchado por sus discrepancias con el
presidente y otros han sido directamente
despedidos
alexandra schieren mucho del sureste en
el cual kirchner en el gesto y algún
whitehouse y el asistente personal de
trump yom agente despedido por un
problema de seguridad luego tenemos
casos muy curiosos como por ejemplo el
de omar osama ni gol hasta diciembre de
2017 asistente del presidente y
directora de comunicaciones de la
oficina de enlace público de la casa
blanca veréis omar osa era básicamente
conocida por participar en realities de
televisión en uno de los cuales en el
aprendiz conoció a donald trump y
gracias a ello pasó a formar parte del
equipo del presidente cuando éste llegó
a la casa blanca
e
[Música]
este pues bien en diciembre de 2017
dimitió de forma repentina alegando que
había visto cosas muy raras que le
habían hecho sentir muy incómoda y le
habían afectado emocionalmente a los
shows fire with and sand y francés
después de fuerza y muy fuerte sabéis
cuál fue su siguiente paso después de
dimitir pues ni más ni menos que entrar
en gran hermano vip donde se ha dedicado
a airear trapos sucios del surrealismo
diario que vivía como empleada de la
casa blanca
currín
a las islas
a menudo ojo tiene atrás para fichar y
eso que siempre ha presumido de que ese
era uno de sus fuertes elegir a las
personas que le acompañan y trabajan
para él menos mal pero vale puede que
algunos de vosotros esté pensando si
alberto lo de su equipo en el ala oeste
se ha ido un poco de madre pero el
gobierno es decir a nivel de secretarios
lo que en otros lugares conocemos como
ministros la cosa aseguró que es
diferente pues me parece que no mucho
atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el gabinete
[Música]
el gabinete el órgano que está formado
por los principales cargos del gobierno
de los eeuu tampoco se salva del
terremoto trump veréis en junio de 2017
se celebró la primera reunión con todo
el gabinete al completo en aquel momento
trump declaró públicamente que había
reunido un grupo extraordinario de
talentos para formar su gobierno pues
bien desde entonces amigos lo menos que
podemos decir es que las cosas han
cambiado desde entonces se han producido
cinco rotaciones en el gabinete que son
más que todas las que tuvo george bush
en sus dos mandatos y más de la mitad de
las de obama todo en sólo un año por
cierto de estos cinco cambios tres han
sido despidos o dimisiones fulminantes
las de reims pruebas con price y la más
surrealista de todas la última la de rex
tillerson secretario de estado y
previamente poderoso ceo de la exxon
mobil la mayor petrolera de los eeuu rex
tillerson amigos fue despedido por
twitter sin que trump se lo comunicará
ni siquiera personalmente
[Música]
de hecho según se cuenta saltándose las
órdenes de su jefe jon kyl y el jefe de
gabinete de donald trump llamó a
tillerson que en aquel momento se
encontraba en plena gira africana para
decirle que el presidente le iba a echar
que regresará a washington y que se
planteara dimitir no está claro si al
final no quiso no se lo creyó o no le
dio tiempo pero el caso es que trump le
fulminó por twitter
[Música]
ahora las apuestas sobre quiénes serán
los próximos candidatos en esta
particular diana del donald trump crecen
como la espuma vengar son secretario de
vivienda david solkin secretario de
asuntos veteranos ryan cinc y secretario
de interior
scott wood director de la agencia de
protección del medio ambiente y también
el poderoso jeff sessions el fiscal
general copan todas las apuestas estos
son los grandes favoritos para ser los
siguientes en ser despedidos por cierto
a este último a jeff sessions trump le
culpa de no haber parado las
investigaciones sobre el tema de la
injerencia rusa en las elecciones
presidenciales que le llevaron a la casa
blanca
trump está harto en su cabeza él es el
presidente así que el isologo él es el
que manda que se han pensado que es eso
de que responsables del fbi y del
departamento de justicia quieran
investigarlo como osan atreverse
independencia de eso nada y ojo amigos
porque trump no se ha cortado ni un pelo
por este motivo ha despedido a
responsables del fbi como james com o
andrew mackay
el mismo motivo también ha señalado a
robert muller el fiscal especial que
investiga la injerencia de rusia en las
elecciones como el próximo en ser
despedido algo que ha hecho atentos que
todo un senador republicano jeff flake
senador por arizona advierta
públicamente al presidente sobre su
posible destitución tal cual como lo
escucháis le rogamos al presidente que
no despida al fiscal especial que no
cree una crisis constitucional el
congreso no puede evitar ese despido
nuestro único remedio constitucional
sería a posteriori mediante el
impeachment pues bien amigos estos son
los motivos por los que trabajar en la
administración trump es algo cada vez
menos atractivo incluso para los
republicanos no hay un gran apetito
entre los republicanos por explorar las
oportunidades de trabajo en esta
administración
ryan williams ex portavoz de mitt romney
por cierto habéis caído en una de las
principales consecuencias que esto tiene
quien va a querer trabajar en esta
administración pensando en un momento si
tuvieses un buen trabajo
lo dejarías todo lo arriesgaría todo
nuestra reputación vuestra carrera
profesional para trabajar en una
administración como esta donde te pueden
despedir mañana con un tuit estoy
convencido que en muchos casos la
respuesta sería no así que una
consecuencia muy posible es que esta
administración la administración trump
termine funcionando como una especie de
aspiradora nutriéndose no precisamente
con los mejores perfiles en fin amigos
así están las cosas por washington y eso
que trump sólo lleva un año en la casa
blanca si te ha gustado este vídeo dale
al botón de like y ayúdanos
compartiéndolo con tus amigos
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]